you know our strength to know our fears
he's my best friend you know how much we
love each other and you know how to use
that love again I know who you are it's
about time
flash moment is Tuesday at 8/7 central
on the CW
our old friends hailed the Waverider
sorry to contact you like this captain
hunter but I cameras putting in more
lives in danger but this is from Barry
Allen it's only for 40 years in the
future the neither can dissipating which
is why you'll keep what I'm about to
tell you the secret even from the rest
of your team score is coming captain
hunter and at some point you're going to
be called back to Central City to fight
it so you need to know that while you
and your team have been in the temporal
zone I made a choice that affected the
timeline as you know whenever you alter
the past those changes affect the
president get compounded in the future
when you return you will be in the new
timeline I created where everyone's past
and everyone's future has been affected
including yours when you come back don't
trust anything or anyone not even me who
sent by you for four years from now
until I realized that I've made a big
mistake and I tried to reset the
timeline put things back to how they
were supposed to be but I but it didn't
work
yes he quit I knew you would come for me
how'd you know I was coming here because
I know everything that happens I've
already lived it
I have such plans for you in the future
ptoo versus charlie's we got to talk all
about sabot are in a huge problem that
they're creating for themselves in
season four it's actually pretty cool
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so you know you're
thinking hey wait a minute
they defeats avatar at the end of the
season or they solve the problem of
sabot are in a really ironic way but why
does that create problems for them in
season four well if we learned anything
from the flash is that rookie berry will
solve problems in a way that also causes
bigger problems later on so we'll talk
about sabot are there's some more
evidence that's why I included those
clips the beginning of this just
reminding you that sabot waar has lived
everything that team flash has lived
moment-to-moment as if he was there
while it was all happening in there
still the very from 40 years in the
future that's talking about the war that
is coming presumably if they're not able
to stops avatar so we'll talk about all
those things but the interesting problem
for season four because then everybody's
wondering about season four stuff is
that we've already gotten synopsis for
episode 22 which is the episode right
before the finale berry goes to get help
from Captain cold because he has nowhere
else to turn so he has to turn to a
villain so we'll talk all about the
logic of that because Captain Cold in
the present should still be dead so
there's a couple of questions that need
to be answered but any time he goes to
help for Captain Cold
there's always a price captain Cole
always walks out with the better end of
the deal so what is Captain Cold going
to get from berry that will help him out
in season four and hurt berry in what
are they doing to stops avatar if not
creating anti Speed Force weapons so you
start to connect the dots in your head
and you're like okay the Rogues
are going to be a big deal in season
four they're probably going to be one of
the big bads it's not the big bat so
what would the Rogues do to up their
game they would get anti speed force
technology which they just did in the
flash comic book a couple months ago
last year as part of the flash rebirth
comic they did this rogues reloaded
storyline where they reintroduced all of
the Rogues into the rebirth universe in
as part of that Captain Cold super
upgraded his gun to take advantage of
the Speed Force so it shoots like Speed
Force enhanced ice that the flash can't
vibrate through so anytime you're going
to build a bunch of weapons to defeat an
evil speedster
careful if you're going to make an
alliance with a group of criminals
because those criminals might borrow
some of that anti speed force technology
that is going to bite you
literally bite you in the ass in the
next season so that's just something to
think about for season four as we move
into the final couple of episodes butts
avatar so you guys have sent me a bunch
of really cool theories about who you
think it could be some of you want it to
be Eddie some of you want it to be
Ronnie some of you even want it to be
Cisco we do know that it's somebody
that's on Team flash so I think that
kind of rules out Eddie because he
hasn't been part of all these adventures
the team Flash's been having in Savitt
art knows about all of this needs to
live through all of it and Eddie's been
dead for a long time so is Ronnie so
that sort of downplays the evidence for
them but think about the way they're
marketing this avatar reveal know your
enemy so Barry says in that trailer for
the next episode I know who you are and
look at the way that they've drawn this
so you have Barry really small on top of
sabotage so it's making sabotage seem
like he's five times bigger than he
actually is but we saw him climb out of
the suit at the end of last week's
episode so we know that it's just a
normal-sized person the suit just makes
him look really big so whoever's in
there it's not a big person is just
somebody with some really badass speed
force technology because sabotage
costume literally absorbs that speed
force lightning both that Jesse quick
threw at him in that redirected back at
her so it is some hardcore advanced
speed force technology and as we know in
rip hunter ship there's a bunch of anti
speed force weapons from the future eel
bars dawn said that he invented a lot of
them so we know that there's a Barry
from 40-plus years in the future so it
sounds like sabotage from even further
in the future and if he is the first
person to ever get speed then maybe he's
just somebody who's jumped around to the
past to the future to the present to
harass people get powers become a speed
gun so the whole idea is that you don't
know when he's from in time he just
jumps around like he doesn't care what
the side effects are which is part of
what Barry did at the beginning of the
season in the big lesson that he has
learned is that you can't do that like a
look at all the damage done to his
relationships and his friendship to his
friend Caitlin snow that is now
full-blown killer frost so saboteur is
an example of a character it did
learn that lesson this is why I think
there's a certain amount of poetic
justice in the reverse-flash will always
walk away chuckling to himself feeling
like he won because in that first
episode what does he tell Barry this
time you're the villain you change time
it wasn't me I get to be the hero so we
still don't know who saboteur is they
haven't confirmed it but is it the
evidence is stacking up metaphorically
in somatically based on what all the
episodes have told us that Barry has
been the villain of the season so far
and he's had to learn all these lessons
so how do you pay for those crimes
everybody is circling around the theory
that Barry is going to go into the Speed
Force at the end of the season to pay
for his crimes that doesn't really
answer the question of what happens this
avatar at the end of the season because
if Barry goes into the speed forest and
that means avatar is free and if they
stops avatar and it turns out to be a
version of Barry how does that work out
but of all the picks my number one is
still Barry number two would be one of
the other people that has Speed Force
powers on Team flash right now so
there's still a couple possibilities but
let me know do you feel like the
evidence is completely stacking up
against Barry being sabotage or do you
still believe that there's better
evidence for another candidate and be
sure to include why you think it's that
other person like that sometimes there's
a big twist but a lot of times the show
has already told you who the big villain
is and it just seems like it's already
done that starting with the first
episode usually the finale serves is a
bookend for what was started and teed up
in the first episode so a line of
dialogue that might have seen like some
throwaway insult from the reverse-flash
sort of serves as the Hat tip for
Barry's journey over the course of the
entire season
realizing that he has been the true
villain even if he's still a good person
trying to do good things so the only
other real big evidence that stacks up
against Barry that isn't something that
the show has talked about is what one of
the producers said Andrew Kreisberg was
talking about season 3 being all about
what it means to have the power of a god
because he really kind of is one if you
have the ability to change time on a
whim that makes you a measure of God in
the reverse-flash kind of thinks of
himself as a minor God in his own right
but that's just because he's incredibly
narcissistic so can't wait to see the
reverse-flash come back and stuff it all
in Barry's face see I told you so
you were the villain and then Russia
to do something really terrible so that
he becomes the villain again but do not
forget the end of season 3 is supposed
to leave on a moment that will leave the
rest of team flash as they tease
wondering how they're going to go
forward so I think that that's just a
hat tip to Barry being lost to them
temporarily until he comes back in the
first episode of season 4 so there's a
lot of big questions and start thinking
about the bonus videos that you guys
want me to do during the off season
before we start getting trailers and
stuff for season 4 in Comic Con and I
know there's a writer's strike that's
getting ready to happen that could
totally derail the beginning of season 4
but I don't think it's going to be that
bad I think there'll be some resolution
and we'll find out in the next week
what's going to happen with that so
there's some big universe changing
update for what's going to happen with
all the TV shows because the writer
stripe would affect all of TV in all of
movies it would be catastrophic I will
totally do an update but don't freak out
yet it's not that bad so what's going to
happen next is that I have new Game of
Thrones new Aquaman to post and episode
1 of American Gods starts Sunday night
so I'll be posting a video for that
after it airs so be sure to check that
out congratulations to Kevin Garrick
here's the new giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video so while you wait
for everything to post here for brand
new Wonder Woman versus Aries and click
here for brand new Star Wars thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight
you